What in the Super Mario world does a '90s
"Godzilla" flick have to do with the new "Mario
Brothers" movie? It's either a Giant Land-sized
Easter egg, or just a goofy coincidence.
"The Super Mario Bros. Movie"
keeps things relatively grounded,
or at least as grounded as a
story about a pair of Brooklyn
plumbers transported to a magical land
called the "Mushroom Kingdom" can be.
As you'd expect with family-friendly fare,
it's a fairly straightforward story. The
evil Bowser wants to marry Princess Peach
and take over the world, so Mario and his
new friends set out to stop him. But there are
plenty of wild places for a follow-up to go.
In the games, Mario has traveled across
the galaxy, explored strange new lands,
and even used a magical cap to mind-control a
T-Rex. The sky's the limit as far as sequels are
concerned, and the movie offers some hints
as to where Mario and Luigi could go next.
One of these clues lies in the
post-credits scene. After Mario and
his team have defeated Bowser and saved
both Brooklyn and the Mushroom Kingdom,
the brothers go about living
in this strange new world.
But they may not be done with their old home yet,
as the scene takes viewers through the
underground before landing on a green-spotted
egg that clearly belongs to none other than
Mario's long-time dinosaur partner, Yoshi.
It's not the first Yoshi hint to pop up in the
film. When Mario, Peach, and Toad travel across
various lands to reach the Jungle Kingdom,
they pass a whole herd of roaming Yoshis.
However, the one in the egg at the end
of the film almost certainly belongs to
the green Yoshi most closely associated
with Mario. It's a clear teaser for Mario
eventually teaming up with Yoshi in the
sequel. But not-so-clear is why the "Super
Mario Bros. Movie" post-credits scene appears to
be referencing 1998's "Godzilla," of all films.
"He looks angry."
Yep, you heard that right.
At theconclusion of that widely-panned flick, after
humanity has defeated the giant monster,
the camera guides the viewer through
the ruins of Madison Square Garden,
landing at one of Godzilla's eggs. It hatches, and
a baby Godzilla emerges, roaring at the screen.
The "Super Mario Bros. Movie"
post-credits scene is weirdly similar,
down to the camera movement, but
there's no hatching. However,
as the screen cuts to black, Yoshi does
emit his signature high-pitched squeak.
Yoshi's inclusion at the end of "The Super Mario
Bros. Movie" could hint at where a sequel could
head. Yoshi became Mario's companion in
"Super Mario World," where Mario and Luigi
go on a vacation to Dinosaur Land with Princess
Toadstool, who is (of course) kidnapped by Bowser.
The baby Godzilla hatching from its egg was
actually supposed to set up a sequel to the
monster flick. In fact, 1998's "Godzilla" was
supposed to set up an entire trilogy, with
the second installment following that Godzilla
growing up and forming an attachment to Matthew
Broderick's character from the first film, causing
him to track the creature to the South Pacific.
Additionally, that baby Godzilla would've
been all grown up with a brood of its own,
wreaking all sorts of havoc. Unfortunately,
the negative critical reaction to the first
"Godzilla" made Sony wary of pursuing
a follow-up, and it never materialized.
Hopefully, "The Super Mario Bros. Movie" doesn't
have the same issue. While the new "Mario"
movie received mixed reviews from critics, it's
expected to do extremely well at the box office.
In fact, it's projected to make roughly $225
million worldwide in its opening weekend,
and if the numbers hold steady, it shouldn't
be long until Mario's off on another big
screen adventure, this time with the
help of his friendly dinosaur steed.